[موسيقى]
مساء الخير بلا جدال الانفاق هي اقوى
اسلحه المقاومه الفلسطينيه وهي ايضا اهم
اسلحه المقاومه في جنوب لبنان هذا السلاح
يحير الاسرائيليين وحلفائهم الامريكان
والانجليز وغيرهم الكل يحاول ان يتعرف على
هذه الانفاق كيف بناها الفلسطينيون كيف
يمكن الوصول اليها كيف يمكن تدميرها
وتحييدها وحرمان المقاومه منها لكن يبدو
ان هذه المهمه صعبه جدا على كل هؤلاء كيف
ولماذا هذه الاسئله انا بطرحها اليوم على
واحد من القلائل جدا في هذا المجال وهو
الاستاذ الدكتور اسامه النحاس استاذ
العماره اللي بدات اهتمامه بالانفاق من
اكثر من 40 سنه زار فيها حوالي 38 دوله
يدرس فيها الانفاق او كما يسميها الفراغات
تحت الارض ولديه خبرات كبيره متراكبه مساء
الخير معنا الدكتور اهلا مساء الخير
منورنا ومشرفنا نورك يا فندم ربنا يخلي
حضرتك ا استاذنك ادخل في الموضوع على طول
لان الفضول كبير جدا لل لفهم تفاصيل ما
يجري يعني في هذه الانفاق هل يمكن ان
تعطينا معالي الدكتور صوره عامه طبعا
حضرتك ما زرت انفاق غزه ولكن زرت انفاق في
حول العالم في كل مكان هل يمكن بناء على
خبرتك وخلفيتك العلميه كاستاذ عماره متخصص
في هذا الجانب ان تعطينا صوره لما يمكن ان
تكون عليه انفاق غزه تمام هو طبعا موضوع
الانفاق ده موضوع يعني قديم قوي عمره اكتر
من 3000 سنه
ا بشكل تاريخي موجود في اماكن كثيره جدا
كان في حروب بتدور وكان في معارج بتدور من
اكتر من 3000 سنه وبالتالي كان لابد ان في
يعني حمايه والحمايه ديت كانت من خلال
انفاق من خلال مدن تحت ارضيه يعني مدن تم
انشائها تحت الارض ويعني مش هنقول تم
انشاءها هي تم حفرها يعني هي يعني كل
الانفاق
بتتحب بتتحب بطريقه يدويه 3000 سنه ما
كانش فيه الادوات والمعدات وال الكلام
اللي هو موجود النهارده ده وبالتالي كان
القصه كلها تعتمد على المجهود الشخصي ف في
مدن كامله كانت بتشيل اكتر من 20000 واحد
ومحفور وعمرها اكثر من 3000 سنه وطبعا تم
الحفر على مراحل يعني من 3000 سنه وبعد ثم
من 2000 سنه ثم من 1000 سنه حسب
الاستخدامات وحسب المشاكل اللي كان
بتستوعب استخدام هذه الانفاق فعندنا امثله
كتير جدا عندنا امثله مثلا في تركيا على
سبيل المثال وده كان ممر بتاع الحرير يعني
احد ممرات واحد طرق الحرير وكان الممر دوت
ممر للجيوش ما بين اوروبا وما بين اسيا
وبالتالي بياخدوا المؤم بتاعتهم من منطقه
اسمها كبادوكيا دي في في منتصف تركيا
تقريبا وبالتالي لما بيجوا بياخدوا المؤن
والميه والاكل والكلام ده كله و فالناس
بتهرب وتحاول تحافظ على كل المنتجات
بتاعتها بان هي تنزل تحت الارض وتقفل
وتيجي الجيوش ديت تحاول ان هي تخش ما
تعرفش تخش ويحصل معارك وتيجي الجيوش دي
تحاول ان هي يعني تعمل حصار فتعمل حصار
لمده مثلا ست اشهر وهم تحت عندهم اكلهم
وشربهم وكل حاجه والتهويه بتاعتهم كل حاجه
موجوده ما فيش اي مشاكل اذا هو سلاح قديم
واحد الامثله اللي حضرتك بت تبرهن ب على
انه سلاح قديم هي منطقه كبد مجوده في
تركيا موجوده على اعماق وصلت لكام في كب
وصلت حوالي من 80 ل 120 متر وطبعا ال 80
من 80 ل 120 م مت ا وده حفر يدوي ما
بنتكلم على حفر عبر مئات السنين مئات
السنين مئات السنين طيب بما انه ده في
التاريخ الح في التاريخ القديم ايه ابرز
الامثله في التاريخ الحديث لانفاق استغلت
عسكريا يعني الانفاق اللي استغلت عسكريا
نقدر نقول ان بتنام ممكن اقرب حاجه او
اقرب مثال وده مثال انا زرته مثال مهم جدا
لان يعني لما بنتكلم على
امريكا ازاي قدرت ان هي الفيتناميين من
خلال انفاق بسيطه جدا عمقها حوالي 10 متر
قدروا ان هم يحفروا الكلام ده عرفوا ان هم
يعيشوا فيه لما جت القوات الامريكيه وبطير
وضربت قنابل زنه 1000 رطل و2000 رطل ونزلت
لاعماق قد تصل لل 10 متر نزلوا 20 مت
الفيتناميين نزل 20 مز 20 متر خلاص 20 متر
ما تقدرش تاثر باي حاجه على الاقل وقتها
يعني وقتها اه يعني الارض بتمتص يعني يعني
حتى حتى حاليا الارض بتمتص القوى
الانفجاريه الارض بتمتصه يعني لما تنزل
قنبله هتاثر اه على الجزء الفوقاني تعمل
لك حفره مثلا بعمق 10 متر انما لو انت
نازل 20 او 30 متر هيبقى تاثير يضعف
مابقاش بقى تاثير اللي هو مباشر اللي كان
موجود على الطبقه السطحيه
الحفر دوت يعني قدروا يحفروا وقدروا
يعيشوا في الاماكن ديت وقدروا ان هم يعني
حتى يعملوا تريكات يعني زي يعني اساليب
بقى معيشه ما هو عايش في مشكله فبيح لها
ازاي الطيران بيجي مثلا على الاماكن اللي
فيها المطابخ ليه لان المطبخ بيطلع منه
دخان فيقدر اللي يقدر تقدر التيار يقدر
يشوف الدخان يوم يضرب المنطقه ديت فعملوا
ايه راحوا جايين الدخان اللي بيطلع من
المطابخ دوت راحوا مدخلين جوه البامبو اح
عارفين اشجار البامبو في شرق اسيا وفيتنام
كتيره جدا ابتدوا يعملوا الوصله ديت وتطلع
تمتد حوالي 500 متر فلما يجي يضرب يضرب
على بعد 500 متر ما يضربش اه يعني الدخان
يمر فيمر في التيوب دي يعني التيوب اه
كانها كانها ماسوره بالضبط كانها ماسوره
فيعني كل دي اساليب بسيطه جدا وقدروا ان
هم يقاوموا بيها زائد طبعا الفخاخ يعني
بيعمل فخ ازاي يعني اساليب كتيره جدا
علشان يعمل فخ ويوقع فيه الجنود اللي
موجودين الخ اللي بينزل فيه خلاص يعني
هيغر هتلاقي كل الكلام ده مسامير وحاجات
بتخش في رجليه وتخش في جسمه يعني التركات
اللي هم عملوها فعلا يعني وصلوا الامريكان
لازم يسيبوا المكان طيب ا احنا عندنا
مجموعه اسئله تتعلق الاول سواء الانفاق في
غزه في جنوب لبنان كانت في فيتنام كانت في
كابوكا في تركيا في تونس في الجزائر حضرتك
لفت دول كتير قوي وادتني فكره عنها قبل
الهوا قبل التسجيل يعني تمام عندنا اسئله
عامه وتنطبق على غزه الان ايضا يعني هو
بدايه كده ازاي المهندسين لما بيبنوا هذه
الشبكه الضخمه اولا سؤال رقم واحد كيف
يمكن بناء شبكه يقال ان هي بتوصل الى اكثر
من 500 كيلو طولا وناس بيقولوا ميل الناس
كلها تخمينات يعني دون ان يلاحظ
الاسرائيليون اللي هم بيراقبوا خطه غزه
ليلا ونهارا هو طبعا الحفر اللي بيتم بيتم
على مراحل وبتحور فراغ ثم تحفر الفراغ من
فراغ تاني فانت بتفرغ التربه اللي هي
موجوده والنهارده بقى فيه اساليب
تكنولوجيه سهل جدا ان يحصل شفط للاتربه
ديت يعني ما بقاش بقى مشكله ان واحد هيشيل
على كتفه ويطلع والكلام ده كله لا ده في
ميكنه وعن طريق الميكانيزم ممكن ان هو
يشفط الاتربه اللي بتطلع دي يبقى في حفار
بيبقى موجود تحت وفي معديت بتبقى صغيره
وتقدر ان هي تحفر الكلام ده يعني مش لازم
تبقى يدويه بقى لان عشان عايز يعمل كميه
ويبقى في تكنولوجيا فعايز ينجز يعني ببتدي
يحفر الكلام ده ويطلع الاتربه ديت وقد
يكون في الجزء دوت متغطي باي حاجه ممكن
متغطي وفي تمويه مثلا بخيمه متغطي في
تمويه مثلا باشجار او نباتات فيقدر يطلع
الحفر دوت ثم يبتدي ياخد الحفر ده شويه
شويه ويبتدي يوزعه اللي هو التراب اللي هو
بيطلع ناتج الحفر فاذا ويقدر بقى يحفر
فراغ من فراغ وينز مص انه عمل نفق اساسي
ممكن منه ممكن منه بقى يحفر ويطلع في
النفق الاساسي ثم يطلع بره اه ويطلع بره
في الوقت المناسب وممكن يطلع بره ده في
مثلا بالليل يعني يعني يعني في يعني سهل
جدا ان هو يبتدي يوزع الكلام ده طبقا
للظروف المناخيه للظروف البيئيه لظروف
مثلا ان شايف ان في طيران وفي استطلاع ف
ما يطلعش يعني واحد قاعد في المكان قاعد
24 ساعه ودي مهمته وهو يعني دي حياته
بالاضافه ان بناء الانفاق او حفر الانفاق
زي ما حضرتك بتقول للدقه قد يتشابه ناتجه
مع بناء المب
العبان اليه انا في المبان الع كل في
الموضوع ان هو يمكن المستجد في في حاله
بتاعه غزه عن اللي انا شفته في حتت كتير
جدا ان هو ابتدى يعمل بري فابريك تد يعني
ايه يعني خرصانه سابقه التصنيع اللي هي
عباره عن ايه الجدران اللي موجوده ديت بقت
وحدات بتتصب بره وتبتدي تخش جوه او تتصبب
برض خرسانه ويبتدي يصب الايه الجدران ديت
ثم الابو اللي موجود اللي هو الجزء الكيرف
اللي هو فوق فابتدا يعمل الحوات اللي
موجوده ديت اللي هي ارتفاع حوالي 180 سم
تقريبا ثم الكيرف دوت اللي هو مثلا قطره
يمكن بيوصل حوالي مثلا نص متر ولا اللي هو
السقف نفسه فبقى في عندي منشا كله من
الخرصان فانت حضرك بتقول ان الجديد اللي
عملوا الفلسطينيين هو فكره الحوائط جاهزه
ال اه يعني جاهزه الصب يعني هو صبها الاول
ودخلها وركبها وركبها ف فكده بيدعم التربه
كمان يعني ما بقتش بقى ان هو يعني في
الاول خالص اللي احنا كنا بنشوف ح كتير
جدا ان هو بيحصل في الطفله او بيحفر في
التربه لما يحفر في التربه او في الصخر
بيقوم يعمل الشكل اللي هو الابوي دوت
علشان ما يحصلش ان هو يهيل ما يحصلش ان
يحصل الحفر الناتج اللي هو بيحفر ممكن
يبتدي
يهيل حواليه يضعف يعني يضعف او يقع يقع لا
هو بيدعمه بقى بالكلام ده عن طريق الايه
الخرسانه اللي هي سابقه الصبر طيب عملنا
ده انا اسف صدي اتفضل ودي تدينا برده فكره
ان انت لو ابتديت تفكر ان انت تغرق الكلام
ده طماه دي كلها في فواصل ممكن تسرب الميه
للتربه نفسها انا هسال حضرتك سؤال عن حوله
الاغراق تمام طيب انا في البدايه ده احنا
ازاي بنيناها من غير ما نصرع انتباه كل
العالم يعني السؤال السؤال التالي انت حك
اجبت ان هو ده ممكن مش صع طب ط السؤال انا
عندي اساسيات حياه انا هعيش تحت في
الانفاق لشهور انا محتاج تهويه محتاج مياه
محتاج صرف صحي كيف يمكن فعل ذلك في
الانفاق سواء في غزه في الجنوب او في اي
مكان في العالم يعني الانفاق بشكل بشكل
عام والفراغات اللي تحت الارضيه بشكل عام
انت بتحتاج كبني ادم ان انت يبقى درجه
حراره مناسبه درجه الحراره كل ما بتنزل
تحت درجه الحراره بتبعد عن الطقس المناخي
الخارجي خاصه لو نزلت مثلا 10 متر هبص
تلاقي ان انت دخلت في في نطاق حوالي
تقريبا 20 22 درجه بكتير و 25 تبقى برره
درجه حراره بتوصل ل 30 و0 و50 وانت جوه 28
تكييف طبيعي تكييف طبيعي وانا بيت في
حاجات كده بيت في حاجات بشكل
فبتن تبص تلاقي بلد زي ايه مثلا يعني مثلا
في في نقدر نقول مثلا في تونس في مطماطه
في تونس انا رحتها مرتين مره في الشتاء
ومره في الصيف بتبقى درجه حراره مثلا
ماينس مثلا خمسه سه وتبقى جوه حوالي 20
تبقى بره درجه حراره في الصيف مثلا توصل ل
50 درجه وتبقى جوه حوالي 28 درجه نفس
الكلام في في استراليا في في كوبر بيدي في
استراليا وسط الصحراء
الاستراليه المناخ هو طبيعي تنزل بت يب عن
الملاك الخارجي ودي احد اساليب التكيف
الطبيعي طيب ده من حيث درجه الحراره انا
بيوصل لي الاضاءه والمياه والهواء والهواء
الاضاءه اذا كان في اضاءه عن طريق
الكهرباء واذا كان في كهرباء واصله يبقى
بتوصل بقى بالكهربا مافيش يبقى ممكن عن
طريق الشعلات ممكن يبقى فيه شعله وبنور
بيها ودي تاريخيا كانت الشعله هي اللي
كانت بتبقى الاساس التهويه شعله يعني شعله
يعني يعني بيبقى ا ممكن يبقى شمع ممكن
يبقى فيه يعني ايه مجال ان انت تقدر تنور
الفراغ اذا ما كانش عنده كهربا يعني اذا
ما كانش عنده كهربا انما هو دلوقتي غزه
فيها كهربا طبعا من الحاجات مهمه جدا
التهويه مولدات مثلا اه مولد صغير ممكن من
الحاجات المهمه جدا التهويه طب انت
التهويه سهل جدا ان هو بيعمل شفت يعني
بيعمل جزء مفتوح في السقف وواصل بداخل
التربه نفسها يعني نازل من خلال طبقات
التربه اللي موجوده ويمكن الجزء دوت بكتير
قوي يبقى ثانيه بوصه 10 بوصه مش اك ف فتحه
موجوده ومستمره وفوق يروح مخبيها مخبيها
بس كده عدد الفتحات عشان لا واحده منهم طب
الفتحات دي بتبقى متوزعه بحيث ان هي تديك
التهويه الطبيعيه ويبقى في فنتليشن بيبقى
موجود ويبقى في الهواء اللي بيسخن بيطلع
بيتص وبينزل هواء بارد مكانه فاذا السيستم
بتاع التهويه ده مدروس ما فيهوش مشكله هل
الصرف الصحي بيمثل الصرف الصحي لا الصرف
الصحي مافيش مشكله لان انت تحت منك ممكن
تعمل بير صرف صحي وتحت منك ممكن تنزل
للميا ج وتوصل لميه جوفيه عشان تجيب ميه
اذا انت ما عندكش مشكله ان انت حتى لو حصل
حصار عليك وزنقت جوه ده انت ممكن تشرب من
الميه
بتاعه المياه الجوفيه اللي هي موجوده طيب
بمناسبه المياه الجوفيه حضرتك وضحتلي حاجه
انا ما كنتش فاهمها يعني يبدو ان الليله
كلها او او التفكير المهندسين وهو بيبني
مرتبط بالاساس بالمياه الجوفيه ا طبعا
منسوب الميه الجوفيه دي حاجه اساسيه طيب
منسوب ميا الجوفيه اولا بيبقى عامل بيحدد
مجموعه من الامور اولها زي ما انا فهمت من
حضرتك الى اي عمق استطيع النزول طبعا يعني
انت عمرك ما هتوفر في ميه فطبيعي جدا ان
انت بتعمل يعني زي بئر والبير ده بينزل
لغايه ما منسوب الميه الجوفيه بتعرف ان
المنطقه ديت منسوب الميه الجوفيه مثلا
مينس كام ماينس مثلا 20 متر ماينس 50 متر
تحت سطح
الارض تحتيها مثلا منسوب مثلا ماينس 100
فاذا انت طبيعي جدا ان انت هتحر في نطاق
الحفر هو ما يوصلش للمايه الجوفيه لان
الميه الجوفيه مش تقدر تحفر بيها وانت
ماتاش محتاج ان انت توصل للكلام ده انت
مجرد ان انت لو نزلت من 20 ل 40 متر اسناف
بالنسبه له وده يمكن اللي يخليني نفكر ان
ممكن الانفاق ديت تبقى لو هي قريبه من
البحر مش هينزل كتير هينزل له مثلا بكبيره
مثلا 20 30 متر لانه
منسوبون هي ممكن تبقى موجوده في المنطقه
ديت تبقى قريبه انما لو في عندك مثلا
تكوينات طبيعيه عبار اره عن صخور وتحجب
الميه بتاعه البحر ويبقى بتخش جوه تلاقي
مناسيب اعمق وتوصل للميه
الجوفيه بحفر مثلا يصل ل 60 و 80 متر ده
ممكن طبعا يبقى موجود الجيولوجيا بتاعه
الارض هي اللي بتحكم الموضوع ده وحركه
الميه والتكوين الصخور اللي هي تحت ارضيه
اللي انت ماتاش شايفها هو بيبقى شايفها من
خلال الجسات اللي هو بيعملها اذا انا
عمق الانفاق في اي بلد بيحكموا الجوفيه
بالاحتياجات منسوب المياه الجوفيه ايه
اعمق نفق او حفر وصل له الانسان ك نفق في
حدود خبره حضرتك يعني حدود خبرتي ان في
كبادوكيا وصلوا 80 متر ووصلوا بعض المناطق
ل 120 متر ل 120 م 120 متر وبعد كده وجدوا
مياه فتوق لا خلاص بقى الميه خلاص مش
هينزل اكتر من كده وهو لما بينزل مثلا 60
متر خلاص بالنسبه له ينزل 80 متر ده خلاص
كده تمام يمكن الانفاق ديت يعني زي ما
كانت الدفاعيه كانت اختباء وقت الهاد
الديني يعني لما طلعت هنلاقي كبادوكيا دي
فوق بيت لحم فالمسيح لما طلعت من بيت لحمه
ولقت ان في اتهاد دييني استقرت فين في
كبادوكيا فعملوا كنايس على عمق المسيحين
المسيحيين اه فنزلوا وعملوا كنايس في
كابادوكيا على عمق 80 متر والكنايس دي
دلوقتي مزارات على فكره فنزلوا 80 متر
وعملوا كنايس بتاعتهم ما فيش اي مشكله
وتهويه وكل حاجه مافيش اي مشكله بالنسبه
لهم ثم بعد كده استقالت المسيحيه دي بعد
كده اتجهت لجورجيا شرقا واتجهت لاوروبا
غربا طب سؤال لحضرتك ولو ان انت بتوحي ان
هذا لا يحتاج الى مهارات هندسيه كبيره
يعني لانه بتقول عملوها من مئات 3000 سنه
معنى كده انه لا تحتاج الى اخبارات هندسيه
استثنائيه لبناء شبكه انفاق ضخمه لما
نتكلم على الحاله بتاعه غزه بالتاكيد ان
هي اصمم بطريقه عسكريه يعني بنتكلم طبعا
لابد ان يبقى
فيه يعني خبره عسكريه لان انت هتطلع
بالفتحه بتاعتك فين وهتطلع منها فين
وفي للشبكه ديت كم فتحه يعني النفق الواحد
ممكن يبقى له ثلاث اربع فتحات يعني احنا
بناخد خبره مثلا من الحيوانات ومن الحشرات
اللي موجوده يعني لما حضرتك لو شفت ثعلب
ودخل الجحر بتاعه مش هتلاقي الجحر ده ليه
مدخل واحد هتلاقي ليه مدخلين وثلاثه النمل
نفس القصه فاذا كثير جدا من الحيوانات
اللي هي بتستخبى وبتنزل تحت الارض والبني
ادم خد الفكره منها والخبره منها يعني في
عندك الانفاق بتاعه النمل دي دي قصه
لوحديها وبينزلوا قد ايه بينزلوا بال 10
متر و 12 متر ويعمل مدينه كامله اه طبعا
بينزل تحت ويعمل مدينه كامله مدينه كامله
للنمل وبيعمل بقى التهويه بتاعتها وا
وازاي يعمل طريقه التهويه اذا احنا
بنستفيد من من التجارب اللي هي موجوده
قدامنا اللي ربنا بع بعت لنا مثلا النمل
بعت لنا كل الحشرات وكل
الحيوانات اللي هي بتستخبى تحت الارض
الجرزان والفران
كل في كلاب صغيره كده بتنزل الكلب
الامريكي دوت وربنا يعني التكوين
بتاعه الضوافر بتاعته يقدر يحفر بيهما فيش
حاجه من الحاجات دي ليها مدخل واحد ليها
مدخلين وثلاثه واربعه حيس ان انت لو جيت
وقفلت الكلام ده هبص تلاقيه طلع من حته
تانيه ومش هتلاقيهم قريبين من بعض ده هو
عامل مت هنا وعلى بعد ماسك خ س متر 10 متر
دي مدخل تاني وتحت بقى باطن الارض عامل
البيت بتاعه وعامل كل الايه الفايلز
بتاعته او ب السؤال لحضرتك انت كاستاذ
هندسه هل انا كسي مهندسين في غزه في جنوب
لبنان في في اي مكان في فيتنام هل كانوا
هم محتاجين خبراء من الخارج يعلموهم ولا
انا لو انا مهندس هو مهندس هو مهندس مهندس
مثلا مدني وفي نفس الوقت يبقى معاه مهندس
ميكانيك عشان عمليه الشفط بتاع الاتربه
ديت ولابد ان يبقى في حد عسكري لان الشخص
العسكري اللي موجود هو اللي هيخطف ايه
المداخل بتاعتك ايه الاعماق اللي انت انت
عايز ايه بالظبط ايه انت متوقع العدو دوت
لما يجيلك لما اسرائيل تخش لك هتخش لك
منين ايه المحاور بتاعه الدخول اللي هي
متوقعه بالتاكيد احنا شفنا الدبابات بتخش
فين بتخش على الغيطان مش هتخش على المباني
يعني مش هتخش تمشي في وسط شوارع انما هتخش
على الاماكن الفاضيه فانت عارف ان في
اماكن فاضيه موجوده مداخل ومخارج وبالتالي
المداخل والمخارج بتاعتك بتصمم بح انت
هتواجه ولا هتعمل كمين وهتلي تجيله من
ضهره اذا كل المواضيع دي دي دراسه عسكريه
بالتاكيد ماهياش ما جتش بالصدفه دي دي خدت
سنين وخدت خبره يعني كافيه وفعلا وصلوا ان
هم عملوا حاجه مميزه مغلبه الدنيا لغايه
دلوقتي يعني اليهود خلاص يعني هم مش مش
قادرين على موضوع الانفاق قبل ما اسال
حضرتك على سؤالين اساسيين يتعلقوا
بالانفاق هل تتوقع ان الانفاق دي بتبقى
مستوى واحد من خبراتك يعني ولا عده
مستويات تحت الارض التجارب كلها اللي انا
شفتها ان هي مستويات مختلفه ده مستويات
مختلفه وبتنزل بسلالم وبعدين تنزل بسلالم
تلاقي مقفوله وبعدين تلاقي سلم بيوصلك
لمنسوب ثاني وبعدين منسوب يطلعك ومنسوب
بينزلك ما هو انت لما بتبدي تبتدي تحفر
وبتحور مثلا في مناسيب بتوصلك لغايه 50
و60 متر ماهياش منسوب واحد فلابد ان انت
في درج من جو ادوار فوق بعضيها اه طبعا
الادوار دي بتوصل لها يعني يعني بتوصل لها
عن طريق سلالم في حاجات بتتقفل لابد ان هي
تتقفل التجارب يعني اللي يشوف تجارب
كبادوكيا هبص لاقي الموضوع سهل جدا مش صعب
هو طبعا صعوبته انها اتحفر وخد سنين وكل
حاجه النهارده في معدات بتسهل لك الوقت
بتسهل لك الامكانيات ان انت بدل ما تحفر
بشكل يدوي وتبذل مجهود والكلام ده لا ده
انت ممكن يبقى الانجاز اسرع سؤال انا
متخيل يعني هل ان لما بينزل
في وضع في حاله غزه او غيرها يعني لما
يعمل مدينه كامله تحت الارض من الانفاق هم
بيقولوا مدينه من الانفاق الى اي حد ده
ممكن اثناء حفر هذه الانفاق وتشهد مدينه
من الانفاق ده تحت الارض يؤثر على سلامه
المباني لا انت النهارده لما بتنزل لعمق ب
30 متر خلاص انت انت بعيد عن الاسات يعني
المباني اللي موجوده في غزه دي كلها اقصى
حاجه هتبقى يعني عمق الاساس يه 10 متر 15
متر 20 متر انت عندك النفق بتاع الازهر ده
ما ك شركت فيه مش كده كنت استشاري من من
الاثار كنت وقت بشغل في هييه الاثار فكان
هو معدي من تحت اثار وبالتالي كان لابد ان
انا احضر معاهم ف النفق ماشي 30 متر تحت
تحت الارض تحت بعض الاثار تحت القاضي يحيى
يعني يعني مسجد الاض المين اه طبعا فطبعا
في يعني يعني في خبرات في الكلام ده وخلاص
مفهومه ومعروفه ممكن طبعا يعمل كراك بسيط
اللي هو مثلا شروخ بسيطه وكذا لكن مش هيصل
انهيار شخ ومعالي الدكتور الغير المصريين
بيشير الى نفق مشهور في القاهره القديمه
اسمه نفق الازهر وهو حفر تحت مدينه تعتبر
مدينه تاريخيه او اثار قديمه حي الحسين
وحي الازار وكل المنطقه اللي هي طبعا فيها
اثار قيمه وبعضها طبعا اساساته ليست يعني
لا اسات بسيطه بس في بعض العمارات اللي هي
اساسها تصل ل 10 و 15 متر اه في المنطقه
ديت يعني كان في حاجات مستجده وحاجات
جديده وبالتالي هو عدى من تحت الكلام ده
كله ما حصلش مشكله وعليه فحفر الانفاق
تالما تحت عمق 10 كبير والاحمال بتتوزع
فمعنى كده ان انت الحفر اللي هو بتاعك ده
ده ما يشكل ابدا اي مشكله دلوقتي في سؤال
مطروح ليه اسرائيل بتهدد هي كان تهديد
قديم واعيدت له الحياه قد يكون كلام في
الهواء وقد يكون كلام جد ان هي بتهدد
بالقضاء على الانفاق
بطريقه الاغراق اغرق الانفاق بمياه البحر
واظن ان مصر كان ليها تجربه في اغراق بعض
الانفاق في سيناء اللي كانت بتسبب لها
مشكله الى اي حد يمكن لهذا التهديد ان
يكون صحيحا وفعالا هو انا عايز الفه نظر
حضرتك ان موضوع ان يحصل اغراق بالنسبه
للانفاق في تجارب حصلت فيه والامريكان
حاولوا يعملوا الكلام ده في فيتنام وفشله
فاذا في في تجارب موجوده وبالتالي لما
تيجي تعمل مدينه كامله وتحت غزه وكلها
انفاق يعني يعني بالتاكيد تاخد في
الاعتبار ان ممكن يبقى في لجوء للموضوع
بتاع ان انا يعمل يعني اغراق
بالمايه الا اه اه طبعا بالتاكيد فان انت
بقى بتستعد ازاي دي دي قصه تانيه خالص
يعني انت اوريدي متصل عن طريق الانفاق ديت
بالميه الجوفيه فسهل جدا ان انت تبق عامل
فتحات توصل ميه الجوفيه الميه تخش لك تنزل
تنزل يبقى في صرف بالنسبه لها على الميه
الجوفيه منها اليها يعني اه والمايه
الجوفيه اللي موجوده دي دي عباره عن انهار
تحت ارضيه
وهتستفيد هنا هنا اساليب في القاهره يعني
ان انت في مناطق الصحراويه كمان ان انت
لما تحب تصرف ممكن تصرف على التربه نفسها
ممكن تصرف على الميه الجوفيه يعني في
بتحصل بالشكل ده فاذا الفكره موجوده
الامكانيه ان هو يغذي الكلام ده بميه طب
ماشي يغذي بميه انا عندي الفواصل اللي هي
موجوده في الحوائط اللي موجو ماه يعني
النفق اللي هو موجود دوت ده عباره عن
حوائط كلها الحوائط دي مش مش مش مقفله مع
بعضيه لكن في فواصل ما بين كل حته
والثانيه الفواصل ديت ممكن ان انا مجرد بس
ان في فتحه في هتبتدي توزع على التربه فذا
ماهياش ماهياش مصمته انت حضرتك بتقول
ببساطه يعني زي ما انا فاهم ارجو ان تصححي
انه هذه الانفاق بنيت على عده مستويات
قاعها او البيس بتاعها هو المياه الجوفيه
بحتاجها علشان اشرب منها بحتاجها ل اصرف
عليها ممكن اصرف عليها ممكن وبالتالي اذا
جت لي مياه امتار
ضخمه او بفعل فاعل من البحر يمكن ان انا
اخد المياه دي تتغلب عليه اتغلب عليه بس
طبعا على المدى البعيد هيكون ل ضرر على
البيئه يعني على المدى البعيد في طبعا ضرر
على البيئه لان انت هتجيب ميه مالحه
وتبتدي تدخلها على ميه حلوه اللي هي
بتاعه الميه الجوفيه فطبعا في يعني في
تلوث هيحصل بالنسبه للمياه الجوفيه ده ما
فيش كلام الحياه على الم المط لكن ما يضرش
المقاومه على المدى المنظور لا على المدى
المنظور المقاومه دي ممكن تعيش لها ست
اشهر بالطريقه دي ولا هيحصل حاجه اه يعني
خالص يعني اه عظيم جدا طيب السؤال الثاني
واعتقد حضرتك اجبت عليه بس نعيده تانيه
الامريكان قالوا لهم طيب احنا ممكن نفكر
في القنابل اللي هي بتهد البنكر او اللي
هي المخابئ اللي تحت الارض ودي بتوصل
لاعماق حوالي 30 و0 متر انا مش عارف
المسافه ما شفناش القصه دي ان هي بتوصل ل
30 متر يعني يعني اقصى حاجه كانت في
فيتنام 10 متر ونزلوا 20 متر اقصى حاجه
دلوقتي معروفه ان هي بتنزل كل الكلام ده
ما بينزلش اكتر من 15 متر اه وبتمص يعني
ماه القنبله هتنزل وتنفجر وال الموجه
التصادميه بتمتصه التربه يعني دي تربه
طينيه او تربه طفليه او تربه رمليه حسب
نوعيه التربه اللي في موجوده في المكان
لان طبعا غزه مش كلها هومو جينياس او
متجانسه من ناحيه التربه انما طبعا اللي
بيحفر بيحفر بيكتشف التربه ونوعيه التربه
وبيتعامل معاها حسب
التكويم الطبيعي بتاع التربه لو تربه
طينيه يبقى عارفها لو تربه رمليه عارف حتى
التربه الرمليه كمان ما هي هتستوي الميه
التربه الرمليه لما تبتدي تغرق بقى بالميه
والكلام ده كله تستو بالكلام ده احنا احنا
تجاوزنا الميه احنا بنتكلم على القنابل لا
القنابل ما هو انت طالما نزلت تحت 60 متر
قنبله ايه اللي هتنزل 60 متر انت حرك كنت
قلت لي حاجه قلت لي في فيتنام لما
الامريكان فكروا في حاجتين القنابل او
الاغراق هم شافوا المستوى نزلوا اعمق من
نزل اعمق منها وهم عندهم مستويات وه عندهم
مستويات اصل الخبره بتيجي من التاريخ يعني
انت عندك في تاريخ للحروب موجود في عندك
الفكره ديت ماهش فكره جديده دي فكره قديمه
زي ما قلت لحضرتك عمرها 3000 سنه
الفيتناميين لغايه 76 ولا 73 يعني لغايه
76 كانوا بيحاربوا الامريكان بنفس الطريقه
فمعنى كده ان دي خبره من اكتر من 40 50
سنه ف حصل تطوير بالنسبه له حصل تطوير
اللي بيجي بقى خدش من من
من من الخبره السابقه ده وكمان بيعديها
بيبتدي يشوف ايه التكنولوجيا اللي ممكن
مثلا يجيب معدات علشان يعمل ضغط بالنسبه
للتربه عشان يعمل يعني يدك التربه بحيث ان
التربه ما تهيل ش فاذا في تكنولوجيا
موجوده وفي معدات موجوده مستجده ممكن
تساعد انا عاوز استدرك خطا انا قلته
وحضرتك صحح لي فيه الفيتناميين تعاملوا مع
خطرين خطر القنابل وخطر الاغراق تمام
الاغراق حضر حضرتك قلت ان هم تعاملوا معاه
لما فكروا ان هم عملوا ايه قفلوا بقى
الفتحات يعني في الفتحات ابتدوا يقفلوها
يعني انت هتغرق طبعا هتخش هنا ميه انت انت
خايف ان انت تخش لا انت ما تعرفش هتخش على
ايه فبعد 10 متر راح قافل خالص الكلام ده
فالميه ما دخلتش بعد 10 متر من العمق من
من العمق ومن مدخل النفق خلاص قفل الكلام
ده بعد 10 متر من مدخل النفق من مدخل
النفق راح قافل خلاص اليه هتخش فيها اه
وفتح في مكان تاني وفتح في حت انيه يعني
ما الفكره ان انت وانت بره ماتاش شايف
حاجه اه يعني الاخفاء التام بتاع الشبكه
ديت هو ده هو ده الاساس ان انت يعني انت
بره النفق ماتاش شايف حاجه ومتوج ان ممكن
يطلع لك من هنا او يطلع لك من هنا او يطلع
لك من ما عندكش رؤيه خالص للكلام ده ولا
في استشعار عن بعدض يقدر يجيب لك الكلام
ده اذا بالنسبه لتجربه الفيتناميين هم
تعامله مع خطر الاغراق باغلاق اللي هو
مداخل الانفاق اللي قد يصل اليها
الامريكان ت تمام تمام وفيما يتعلق
بالقنابل هم نزلوا الىى عم ابعد من وص
ابعد من وصول القنابل الا طيب ده بياخدنا
للسؤال ولو ان حضرتك اجبت على جزء منه
صعوبه الاكتشاف ليه يعني دلوقتي الامريكان
والاسرائيليين ومعاهم دول من حلف شمال
الاطلسي زي بريطانيا فاعلين في محاوله
اكتشاف الانفاق تمام ليه كل دول عاجزين عن
اكتشاف ا الانفاق يعني لان الانفاق دي
ماهياش سطحيه الانفاق دي بتنزل على الاقل
10 15 متر فانت بتنزل خلاص وانس ان انت
نزلت يعني تحت الارض وبعمق دوت خلاص ما
فيش حاجه تجيبك اللي هيجيبك لازم يكون على
الارض يعني يبقى في عندك مثلا سونار وعلى
الارض عشان تقدر تعرف ان في هنا نفق ولا
لا لكن بالطيران لا بال السنار ليه ما
بيكتشف الانفاق دي لا ده السنار بقى ده
انت لو لو انت جوه المكان ما انت لو جوه
المكان خلاص بقى هيبتدي يصطادك اه يعني ما
خلاص انت بقيت واجه الواده يعني دلوقتي كل
الكلام ان الحرب من منسوب صفر يعني
المسافه مافيش مسافه مسافه يعني اما
مواجهه مباشره او على بعد 10 15 متر طب
ليه لما بيوصلوا لاحد الانفاق يعني حضرك
اجبت بس انا عاوز الاجابه تبقى اوضح انا
وصلت ك كاسرائيل او غيره يعني انا وصلت
النفق ليه النفق ده ما بيبقش طرف خيط
يقودني الى الشبكه كلها لان النفق ده
بالتاكيد الشبكه ماهياش متصله بعضيه
بالكامل يعني بتبقى
نفق موجود هنا ومتصل ويه فروع وممكن يبقى
له نهايات ميته نهايات ميته يعني ايه يعني
لما تخش هبص لاقي النفق دوت خلاص اتصد في
في الوش فانت ماتاش عارف بيقوم يطلع لك
واحد من ايه من نفق من نفق تاني ثانوي اه
ويصطاد جوه
اذا يعني الشبكه كلها مش كلها منفذ على
بعلا مش منفذ على بعضيه يعني الشبكه
الشبكه ممكن تبقى مجموعه شبكات وتبقى
مجموعه الشبكات ديت كل شبكه ليها الفروع
بتاعتها
وده وده ده اللي موجود في في كثير جدا من
الانفاق اللي انا شفتها سواء في تركيا
سواء في فيتنام ما فيش يعني مش معنى كده
ان انت دخلت النفق ده يبقى انت اكتشفت كل
الشبكه لا طبعا وبديهي انه صاحب الانفاق
او الدوله او الجيش او المقاومه اللي بنت
الانفاق لديها خريطه بهذه الانفاق اد اكيد
طبعا ومنته السريه بالنسبه لها اه على
فكره يعني الكلام ده قديم جدا يعني في حفر
الهرم والاوض اللي هي جوه الهرم كان لما
بيبتدوا يحفروا كل الاوض بتاعه الدفن
بتاعه الاهرامات او الدفن بتاعه المقابر
اللي بيحفر الكلام ده كان بيموتو في
الاخر وكان برض بيبقى فييه بيار علشان
يقدر ينزل التابوت وينزل الكلام ده كله او
ينزل الجثمان وفي الاخر اللي اشترك في
الكلام ده بيبقى خلاص بمعزل عن الكلام ده
بيقتلوه بيقتلوه بزل مجهود وعمل كل حاجه
لكن خلاص راحوا والسر معاه وانتهت واللي
كان بيقوم بالكلام ده الكهنه اللي موجودين
في مثل متاخد من الفرعان جزاء سنمار انه
يا ابني وفي الاخر طبعا ثم يكافئه علشان
يعني يتاكد ان هو اقتلوا هم الاسرائيليين
اعلنوا من حوالي 48 ساعه احنا بنسجل
النهارده الحلقه اظن النهارده يوم 18 تمام
18 ديسمبر اعلنوا اظن يوم 16 ديسمبر ان هم
وصلوا لنفق كبير تمام وبعدين انا بعتت
لحضرتك النفق فانت سخرت من الفكره ايوه
ايه بقى يعني ليه تبعد ان يكون ما وجده
الاسرائيليون نفقا هو ده مش نفق يعني هو
بعد اذن حضرتك يعني انا ما اقدرش ان انا
اعمل نفق حربي وبالحجم دوت انت وجدته ك
ولا حرف انتخاب اه طبعا ده ده نفق تخش فيه
التريلات اه فده ممكن يكون مخازن ممكن
يدخل منه سلاح ويخزنه وبعدين ينقله في حته
ثانيه ممكن يدخل يعني لما نشوف
الاستخدامات بتاعه الفراغات تحت ارضيه
ماهيش كلها عسكريه ده ممكن تخزن فيه مؤن
ممكن تخزن فيه تقر فيه منتجات زراعيه
ممكن تخزن فيه حاجات كتير جدا فاذا الحجم
دوت ده حجم تخزين مش حجم مقاومه يعني مش
حجم ان انت ايه بتستخبى عشان تقاوم ولا
بتعمل تركه علشان تقدر تلتف ولا الكلام ده
كله لا ده ده بالنفق وظاهر كان بيستخدم
يعني انا متوقع ان ده كان بيستخدم في
الحياه العاديه اللي هي موجوده وواضح يعني
ده المدخل بتاعه واضح بالحجم دوت انت انت
محتاج ان انت يبقى الفوهه بتاعه المدخل
تبقى مداريه وتبقى مغطيها ومش عارف ايه
انما ده عامل لك مدخل وفي شارع بيؤدي ليه
يعني ده مش نفق ان
ان الاعلام الاسرائيلي بيقول ده نف بيقول
نف ده ده عايز يحدد يعني يحس ان هو كسب
حاجه ان هو اكتشف حاجه انما ده استخدم في
استخدامات ثم سابوه سابوه مفتوح زي ما
بتعمل اي نفق هناه يعني نفق تحت تحت شارع
ولا حاجه عشان يعدي ممكن تعدي مركبات من
هنا لهنا انما مش معنى كده وبعدين هو حتى
بيقول لك ان هو النفق طوله ومحدود ماهش
مستمر ونفق مستقيم يعني ماهواش ما هواش
معمول ك خدعه كخد او او طريقه علشان يقدر
يستخبى من العدو او يهاجم العدو واضح فعلا
ان الموضوع ده من الصعب جدا ان اسرائيل
تقضي عليه يعني ده ده فعلا في صعوبه شديده
يعني صعب ان انت توصل للشبكه ديت صعب ان
انت تكتشف ممكن تكتشف جزء انما تكتشف كل
الشبكه شبكه 500 كيلو حسب اللي بيتقال 500
كيلو دي دي مش سهله انت ممكن تشتب يعني
ممكن تخش في الشبكه ديت ما تعرفش تطلع
اللي يعرف يطلع يطلع منها اهل البلد يعني
في كبادوكيا مثلا بيعملوا دلوقتي زيارات
عشان تقدر تنزل وتشوف شبكات اللي موجوده
والمدن اللي تحت الارضيه والكلام ده كله
اذا ما كنتش نازل مع تور جايد يبقى مش
هتقدر هتوه في ناس نزلت علشان تعمل خرايط
للكلام ده و مهندسين ونزلوا وحصل مثلا
انهيارات وما رجعوش فاذا الموضوع مش سهل
ان ان انت تخش وسط الشبكه ديت وتكتشف
وتقدر تحارب الناس اللي هي موجوده تحت ده
ده انا انا بعتبر ان فيها استحاله انا
عاوز استاذن حضرتك
في وعد يعني الوعد الاولاني ان انا طرحت
اكبر عدد من الاسئله وطبعا الهدف ده
الحقيقه انا مش بحاول ان انا اسعد
الاسرائيليين يعني اسرائيل عن مهندس انا
بحاول نتخيل مجر تخيل والتخيل ده يعني من
خلال الخبره التاريخيه لكن يعني ايه اللي
موجود يعرف انا عملت مره حلقتين بقول من
اين اتت المقاومه بسلاحها من اين اتت
المقاومه باموالها فبعض الاصدقاء اللي هم
يعني قلقانين جدا قولت انت بتقول لهم ليه
ما مش بقول لهم هم عارفين كل حاجه بس مش
عارفين يعني هم لديهم مهندسين ومهندسين
العالم كله بيحاولوا يوصلوا للشبكه مش
عارفين انا هدف الحل ان احنا نحاول نتعرف
على ملامح اقوى اسلحه المقاومه ده الهدف
الاولاني لكن انا طرحت الاسئله اللي هي
تطرا على ذهني انا ك صحفي يعني لكن اكيد
اخرين لديهم اسئله اكثر
فاستاذنتها اخرى نجاوب فيها على اسئله
حضراتكم اللي ممكن تطرحوها ونطرح موضوع
ثاني لانه الانفاق الحقيقه احنا اتكلمنا
عن البعد العسكري بس انت لما بدات اهتمامك
بالانفاق سنه 79 في رساله ماجستير على
ماتما رساله ماجستير عن عماره الصحراء اه
انت بداتها كلا تنميه ك تنميه وازاي تقدر
تتاقلم في المناطق الصحراويه عن طريق ان
انت بتنزل وتكون فراغات تحت ارضيه فاحنا
في حاجه برض ان احنا ناخد فكره
عن الانفاق والكهوف والفراغات زي ما حضرتك
بتفضل تسميها كمهندس يعني ونتكلم على جانب
اخر التنميه والاقتصاد
وممكن الدول المختلفه تستفيد من هذه من
هذه الانفاق بكيد ليها استخدامات مختلفه
كتير مش مجرد الاستخدام العسكري بس ده
جانب يعني وحيد اللي هو الاستخدام العسكري
لكن ل هي اكثر مثلا من 10 استخدامات
مختلفه انت بتثير فضولنا وا استاذنك نور
جده لحلقه قادمه باذن الله شكرا جزيلا
لحضرتك وشكرا لكم وفي انتظار اسك
وتعليقاتكم الى اللقاء